Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Linus.
Happy Birthday Tim.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertsechsundsechzig vom Dreißigsten Oktober zwanzig zwanzig. Kurz vor Lockdown und kurz nach.
Lockdown.
Ja und dem zweiten weißt du noch damals der zweite Lockdown.
Zweiter Lockdown. Was haben die? Ein Theater.
Da haben wir noch gedacht, dass damit dabei könnte's bleiben. Mhm. Ja und äh ein Tag nach äh Geburtstag.
Ja, neun Jahre Lokbuchnetzpolitik. Ja, will man nicht meinen.
Ganz schön viel eigentlich, ne? Wenn's fiese wird.
Übrigens zwei Tage nach dem Geburtstag, weil der Geburtstag ist am achtundzwanzigsten und wir haben den dreißigsten.
Stimmt.
Ist ja auch übrigens so, das kann man ja durchaus auch mal hier sagen, dass ich den Tim daran erinnern musste. Ist ja nicht so, als würde der Tim sich an Hochzeitstag erinnern, ne, also.
Äh du ist äh äh schon so, dass ich das hier als festen Kalendereintrag äh.
Weil du dich nicht dran erinnern kannst.
Ich bin so äh fokussiert auf den anstehenden fünfzehnten Geburtstag, der mir da eben da weißt du, das macht mich alles ganz irre.
Ich bin fokussiert auf, äh aber das habe ich ja, glaube ich, schon mehrmals gesagt, auf den so dritten, vierten, fünften November.
Das ist gerade mein äh mein großes Ding. Aber.
Unser allergrößtes Ding ist das. Du bist.
Party, die Party, ich ich hatte eigentlich wollte ich ja tatsächlich eine größere Party feiern,
Wenn es denn soweit sein sollte, dass der unwahrscheinliche Fall eintritt, den man gar nicht erst beschreien will, dass er nachher nicht eintritt oder so. Aber sage ich mal so eine eine Flasche Schampus wird ja auch nicht schlecht, ja.
Ähm würde ich zumindest bereithalten für den Fall der Fälle. Ja? Aber darf man nicht.
Ist es nicht so weit. Das auf jeden Fall äh unsere unsere vorerst letzte Sendung in garantiert dunklen Zeiten.
Es könnte sein, dass also das ist halt echt so. Es könnte sein, dass zwanzig zwanzig sich am Ende als gar nicht so schlechtes Jahr herausstellt. Ne? Also die die Abwahl, Donald Trumps wäre auf jeden Fall die beste Nachricht, zwanzig zwanzig.
Nicht schwer, aber äh sie wäre es. Übrigens, äh noch ein bisschen Eigenlob, ähm.
Neun Jahre Lokbuch Netzpolitik heißt auch neun Jahre keine Werbung, kein ewiges Gettel, dass man irgendeinen YouTube-Kanal abonnieren soll. Keine ähm.
Ja irgendwelche Solibeiträge, die eingefordert werden oder sonstiges, ähm wir machen einfach einen Podcast.
Finde ich, finde ich jedes Mal frage ich mich, äh ob ich der Einzige bin, der noch alle Tassen im Schrank hat oder ob ich der einzige bin, der so blöd ist, det nicht den ganzen Tag zu machen.
Muss ich wirklich sagen, ein bestimmte Podcast kann ich mir deshalb nicht mehr anhören.
Ja, na ja, es gibt ja noch mich, also von daher sind wir schon zwei.
Wir sind inzwischen eins, nach neun Jahren, Tim, ist das eine Symbiose? Wenn du, das ist äh Linus Tim. Oder Tim Linus, das ist eins, das ist wie so ein altes Ehepaar.
No. Du meinst, alles ist eins.
Außer der Null. Wer von uns ist denn die Null?
Die Null, das ist der äh Geist, der stets verneint.
Oh, das wäre dann ich.
Okay, also ich bin die Eins, du bist null. Hätte das schon mal geklärt hier in unserem in unserem Verhältnis. Ist ja auch mal was.
Der Bezug ist natürlich hier zu einem Kinofilm, der dessen Releasedate, ja, wird sein, der vierzehnte Januar zwanzig einundzwanzig.
Was äh natürlich für einen Kinofilm Release ungefähr das Beste verfügbare Datum ist, was du,
Überhaupt haben könntest, ja? Also so zum Peak der zweiten Welle im im kältesten Monat, den dir äh das Jahr üblicherweise bereithält, ja,
ähm.
Dritte Welle ist das dann wahrscheinlich schon. Ja, klar.
Das ist schon dritte Welle. Im dritten Lockdown, ja genau, im mitten im dritten Lockdown, der.
Wir lachen aber, das ist wirklich ein bisschen schade.
Es scheint, alles ist eins, alles ist eins außer der Null. Sehr schöner äh Filmtitel und das ist ein Film, der sich mit dem.
Leben und Wirken von insbesondere wow Holland auseinandersetzt. Ähm wir haben im ich glaube vor,
zwei Jahren im äh Jahresrückblick des CCC dafür schon darauf schon aufmerksam gemacht, dass es diesen Film geben wird.
Und den hat äh gedreht oder ja gemacht ähm haben den Tanja Schwerdorf und,
und der äh Klaus Mack ist vor allem äh bekannt für den Film B Movi, was ist, wie heißt er? Lasst and Sound in Westberlin, glaube ich
sehr schöne ähm.
Dokumentation so über die ja Achtziger, Neunzigerjahre, Musik ähm Techno Euternitive Szene in Berlin.
Finde ich sehr äh der ist auch wirklich sehr gelungen dieser Film.
Hab ich auch erst vor kurzem das erste Mal so richtig komplett genossen, ist auf jeden Fall Klassiker, aber Klaus Meck ist natürlich auch noch für einige andere Filme äh bekannt.
Ja und äh von daher ist das in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine eine Ehre äh für den Club und war Holland, dass äh er dieses Projekt aufgenommen hat.
Ohne Grund, weil der kannte war Holland auch noch. Klaus Weck kennt, glaube ich, eh alle. Wenn wir den irgendwie über irgendwelche Prominenten redest, sagt er, ja, ah,
Tonsteine färben, ja. Äh oder ähm ähm hier wie heißen die Nummer? Sie lauten da. Neubauten und was nicht alles.
Ja, halt diese ganze Punk Szene,
er hat ja auch den Film gemacht, so über Cyber Punk, Gegenkultur, davon war wiederum war Holland ein großer äh Freund von, also das hat sich alles gegenseitig befruchtet und das war ja der so ein bisschen so eine, so eine Keim, so ein intellektuelle Keimzelle
in den achtziger Jahren, wow, damit halt auch der Club so ein bisschen Teil davon war, aber was eben eigentlich in,
In alle kulturellen und Tiefen so einstieg, ne? Also sowohl Musik als auch Kunst äh Theater, Kultur, was weiß ich. Ähm,
einen Gruß, ein großes Gemengelage und aus diesem hm ja aus diesem Umfeld heraus kommt halt jetzt ein Film,
wo ich nur so sagen kann, da bin ich voller Erwartungen eigentlich, dass das ein ganz angemessenes Porträt sein dürfte.
Ich habe ihn schon gesehen.
Kannst du noch mehr Andeutungen machen als ich.
Äh hast du den nicht mitgeguckt? Bist du da nicht gekommen?
Na ja, in einer frühen.
Rohschnitt hatten wir, glaube ich, bei mir geguckt, warst du da nicht dabei? Da durfte man sich noch versammeln.
Doch, da war ich dabei, aber ja, könnte man doch zusammen sein. Also ich ich weiß ja nicht, wie das Endergebnis jetzt ist. Der war ja definitiv noch nicht.
Stimmt ja, wurde noch, äh wurde noch ein paar Sachen geändert, ja.
Aber ja, genau. Das ist also es ist natürlich tragisch, dass das äh Kino-Release irgendwie am vierzehnten Januar sein wird, weil.
Also es eigentlich von niemandem zu verlangen ist, dann ins Kino zu gehen, wobei man gleichzeitig sagen kann, also in der Zeit ins Kino zu gehen, ist wahrscheinlich komplett gefahrlos, weil kaum jemand so verrückt sein wird, dann ins Kino zu gehen,
und ich hatte das äh auf äh Twitter ein bisschen auch darauf aufmerksam gemacht und da sagten halt einige, ja kann man da nicht irgendwie, ne, so ein äh Release machen, digital release oder was nicht alles,
ähm nicht ohne Weiteres, weil es eben in den Film Förderrichtlinien quasi vorgeschrieben ist, dass eine Kinoverwertung stattfinden muss.
Und das auch äh wichtig ist für irgendwie die unterschiedlichen Filmfestivals und oder wo man sich dann, wo man den noch einreichen kann und so
Und dann äh entsteht eine sechsmonatige Wartezeit, bis man den Film dann in Form von DVD oder sowas verwerten kann, was dann? Das ist das einzig Positive an diesem Januar-Release oder das
Positive. Das heißt, irgendwann im Juli,
August könnte man diesen Film auf DVD anbieten und das wäre immer noch vor dem Vierzigjährigen Geburtstag des Chaos Computerclubs, der nämlich dann,
zwölfter September ähm zwanzig einundzwanzig stattfindet. Insofern haben wir dann wenigstens zum vierzigsten eine DVD.
Oder eine Blu-ray. Ja, ist doch schon mal was. Raus können wir nicht, können wir dann auch im Sommer drin sitzen und Fernsehen gucken.
Ich finde das auf jeden Fall sehr schön, dass
äh baue hier auch im Fokus steht, weil ich finde, dass er bisher ähm was so ein bisschen die Geschichte des Klubs äh betrifft, so in der in der in der Wahrnehmung der letzten Jahrzehnte etwas zu wenig im Mittelpunkt stand, ähm aber dann eben doch äh wirklich eine eine wichtige Person dann so am Anfang war
und ja, das wird einen neuen Einblick geben in das ganze Chaos.
Der Film zeigt mit cleveren Montagen wie die großen Fragen unserer Gegenwart,
Gegenwart, das Leben und Wirken war Hollands durchzogen. Gerade für die heutige Dynamik des Internets, in der einem
Meinungen nicht nur eine freie Äußerung, sondern immer auch eine Waffe. Es wirkt, die Hacker-Ethik des CCC wie ein Mahnmal zivilgesellschaftlicher Werte. Übrigens, sollte man auch äh sagen, die die quasi die Hauptrolle,
des Erzählers, in dem äh Film spielt Peter Glaser.
Ähm das ist also ähm auch nicht kein kein Unbekannter, ja. Erster Chefredakteur, der,
Datenschleuder.
Was damals sicherlich noch 'ne andere also jetzt bei weitem nicht so wild wie man sich das vorstellt erzählt der auch in dem Film und Inge Burg Bachmann Preisträger eigentlich ein doch
deutschlandweit bekannter und geschätzter Autor.
Ja, eine ganz, ganz feine Feder und wirklich ein akribischer, detaillierter,
Beobachter und Berichter eigentlich dieser dieses ganzen dieser ganzen digitalen Revolutionen der letzten dreißig, vierzig Jahre, also,
Peter Glaser hat da wirklich immer den den Finger an die richtige Stelle aufgelegt und schafft's einfach so mit seiner blumigen Sprache äh alles sehr sehr treffend zu umschreiben. Ganz grandios.
Das ist.
Also das ist ein Film, auf den man sich freuen kann und wer weiß, wer weiß, wie sich das äh wie sich das ausstehe, aussieht ähm in im Januar, vielleicht kann man dann doch gefahrlos ins Kino gehen.
Ähm zumindest die DVD, denke ich, sollte bei allen schon mal auf der Wunschliste erscheinen.
Von Peter Glasers Eigenbeschreibung finde ich irgendwie auch nochmal vorstellungs äh äh würdig. Wurde, wurde,
Ja genau, äh wurde allerdings in der Wikipedia als äh unzutreffende Formulierung natürlich verworfen, wie soll das anders sein? Peter Glaser, neunzehnhundertsiebenundfünfzig als Bleistift in Braths geboren.
Wo die hochwertigen Schriftsteller für den Export hergestellt werden, lebt als Schreibprogramm in Berlin. Computerinteressiert.
Ja. Tja und ja, Ehrenmitglied des Computerclubs, ne?
Mitglied des Chaos-Computer-Clubs, ja.
Nun denn, also so viel äh der der Werbung äh über einen Film, auf den wir uns lange gefreut haben, der ähm.
Hoffentlich eben im äh späteren Release als äh Stream oder DVD noch ähm seinen,
späten Erfolg dann feiern kann, weil es wirklich bitter ist jetzt auf diese Weise halt dieser Corona-Lockdownsituation zum Opfer zu fallen.
Ja. Und jetzt.
Machen wir nochmal äh nach diesem Werbeblock.
In dem Podcast, der so stolz darauf ist, euch keine Werbeblocks vorzuhalten. Außer es geht irgendwie um uns.
Oder unsere Buddys, in dessen Sonnenschein wir uns dann äh beleuchten lassen können.
Ich wurde von einigen äh also immer mal wieder in letzter Zeit von äh Hörerinnen und Hörern eher äh im Vertrauen gefragt, ja hier ähm kannst du mal was sagen zu den Telegram-Drogengruppen.
Was ist das denn? Ja, da gibt's Telegram-Gruppen.
Da sagt man so, was man äh was man braucht und wo man ungefähr ist. Und dann ähm meldet sich danach privat jemand bei einem und äh,
man klärt dann hier irgendwie die äh die Situation ab, ja? Und dann kommt das äh ich weiß, also der Begriff ist, glaube ich, der hat sich inzwischen etabliert, äh Kokstaxi, ne.
Dann kommt das Koks-Taxi. Da gibt's übrigens ein wunderschönes Teil auf YouTube, diese wie der Umlauf oder wie der heißt,
Kokstaxi anbietet in ähm Obst, Obsttaxi. Also vielleicht muss man wohnen ja nicht alle in Berlin. Wir haben ja äh auch immer noch äh Hörerinnen in den äh anderen Regionen Deutschlands.
Obwohl wir die fortwährend beleidigen. Ähm.
Folgendes, also Kokstaxi ist wirklich eine geniale Idee der der Operational Security kann gar nicht schief gehen. Du verteilst Visitenkarten, auf denen deine Telefonnummer steht.
Leute rufen dich an und äh oder oder oder schreiben dir SMS und bestellen bei dir äh Drogen und du fährst dann dahin und bringst sie denen, ja? Äh also eine eine Geschäftsidee wirklich für die für die,
klügsten unter den klügsten.
Also sowohl da anzurufen als auch da dran zu gehen an der Nummer, äh erfordert wirklich äh so ein bisschen ähm ja ich sage mal so Lockdown-Affinität, ja, weil.
Ähm,
Und äh genau. Ach, wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt schon irgendwie mal äh genau oder äh äh diese diese wäre das mit diesen Umlauf oder wie der heißt, nicht kennt. Wunderschön,
Der verteilt halt Visitenkarten für Obsttaxi. Und äh da rufen dann natürlich Leute an, ja? Und dann gibt der denen halt Obst.
Für dich. Sehr gut, ja. Ähm okay.
Aber jetzt über Telegramm.
Genau, irgendwann hat sich rumgesprochen, dass das wahrscheinlich nicht so eine gute Idee ist.
Und Telegram wiederum ähm hat natürlich den den Vorteil, dass man da ähm.
Einen, also die ID, die man dort ähm mit der man dort in einem Chat auftritt, ist nicht notwendigerweise die Telefonnummer. Man kann da also sagen, zeigt den Leuten irgendetwas anderes an. Das heißt, du kannst über äh Telegram kommunizieren, ohne.
Deine, im Zweifelsfall auf dich registrierte beziehungsweise äh
das Problem bei der Telefonnummer ist ja nicht unbedingt, dass sie auf dich gemeldet ist, sondern auch, dass du sie ja die ganze Zeit mit dir rum trägst, ne? Das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendwelche Polizei, deine Telefonnummer hat, dann können sie diese Ortungen machen.
SMS und damit dann äh relativ gut auch Beweise gegen dich sammeln, ne? Und vor allem relativ einfach herausfinden, wer du bist. Ähm.
So. Das hast du bei Telegram nicht. Das heißt, du hast im Prinzip einen anonymen Chat,
und oder ein Pseudonym-Chat und deswegen meinten alle, es wäre jetzt eine ziemlich coole Idee, ihre Drogengeschäfte darüber abzuwickeln
bedenken aber nicht das gleiche Problem, was alle Drogenhändler immer haben. Du musst diese Ware übergeben, ja? Mit anderen Worten, du kannst zwar in deiner anonymen Telegram-Gruppe sein, am Ende fährst du aber mit dem Auto vor, das Auto hat ein Kennzeichen,
und du steigst da aus und machst begehst dann halt eben eine Straftat durch die Übergabe dieser Substanz.
Und was noch dazu
ist das halt, sage ich mal, obsäckmäßig so ein bisschen problematisch, wenn du achttausend Leute insgesamt in in verschiedenen Gruppen hast. Und so kam es, wie es kommen musste, äh in der Nacht auf heute gab es eine Aktion gegen dreizehn Männer, die über diese Chat,
Drogen verkauft, beziehungsweise den Handel damit ermöglicht haben sollen. Insgesamt dreißig Objekte durchsucht,
und neun dieser Telegram-Gruppen, was wahrscheinlich relativ geringe Anzahl ist, im Vergleich zu der Anzahl, die es gibt. Ähm
wurden übernommen und da gibt's dann jetzt so eine schöne ähm,
da kommt dann so eine Grafik. Diese Gruppe wurde übernommen und wird jetzt ausgewertet, was natürlich auch scheiße ist für die ganzen ähm Kunden, die äh sich da drin befinden.
Ähm aber das ja, äh hätten sie vielleicht äh sich äh vorher überlegen müssen. Ähm gehandelt wurde in den Gruppen wohl primär mit Cannabis und Kokain.
Und krass. Äh in den, bei den Durchsuchungen hier in den dreißig Objekten wurden vier Kilogramm Drogen,
acht Waffen und achttausend Euro Bargeld und diverse Datenträger beschlagnahmt. Also da scheint der Polizei mal wieder eine relativ,
große ein relativ großer Schlag gelungen zu sein und den betone ich natürlich ein bisschen auch deshalb hier, weil.
Dass ähm eben gelungen ist, trotz dieser vermeintlich äh sicheren Plattform Telegram, wo alle mit Pseudonym arbeiten,
nämlich einfach nur dadurch, dass sich die Menschen eben auch um diesen Handel abzuschließen, treffen müssen. Im Zweifelsfall ist die Polizei also einfach da rein gegangen, ähm,
was bestellt und ist dem Typen danach hinterher gefahren, ne? Also so, also einfach ist es äh und genau deshalb äh äh,
hatte ich bei diesem Geschäftsmodell,
schon immer äh meine Zweifel, ob das so belastbar ist. Ähm jetzt sollen also einige der Beschuldigten als Betreiber dieser Gruppen äh agiert haben, also haben diese Gruppen quasi.
Administriert oder sowas, ne? Und andere haben da in diesen Gruppen eben ihre wahren
Fall geboten und es gab da wohl auch irgendwie einen Status als verifizierte Händler, dass äh dieser verifizierte Händler teilt, ist natürlich immer ein bisschen problematisch für.
Die Betreiber solcher Gruppen, die ja immer sagen könnten, ey, keine Ahnung, was in der Gruppe los ist und in der Gruppe ist ja sowieso nichts passiert, weil die der tatsächliche Handel ja äh in Privatnachrichten äh stattgefunden hat, aber.
Ähm da dadurch, dass sie ja quasi dann verifiz Händler verifizieren, machen sie sich spätestens ähm der Beihilfe,
schuldig und ich gehe weiterhin davon aus, dass sie.
Sowohl Gruppenbetreiber als auch Händler hier natürlich ein bisschen unter einer Decke gesteckt haben, weil wenn du tatsächlich so eine Gruppe administrierst und da sind irgendwie,
so viele Leute drin und die Gruppe ist für diese viele Menschen eben der Marktzugang beziehungsweise für,
für die Händler der Zugang zu diesem Markt, dann kommst du natürlich sehr schnell auf die Idee, da ähm diese Position, die du hast als Administrator der Gruppe, auch zu deinem Vorteil zu nutzen, ja? Also.
Leuchtet ein. Ja, also, dass das nicht gut gehen kann, war ähm irgendwie.
Ganz also war wahrscheinlich äh absehbar.
Achttausend Leute in einer Gruppe oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Fall ja neun, aber das heißt immer noch, äh ne äh knapp unter tausend ähm Personen in einer Gruppe ist schon ähm.
Machen die denn da alle?
Fragen,
also ich ich äh habe ja meine meinen Telegram Agentenaccount zur Beobachtung von Attila Hildmann, aber das war mir genug Bekloppte. Insofern äh habe ich tatsächlich nicht großartig,
in Drogengruppen recherchiert.
Mensch, Mensch, Mensch, kannst gegen deine Natur? Wie hältst du das aus?
Kann ich aber auch erzählen, wie äh mir wurde auch mal so eine ähm mir wurde auch mal so eine ähm,
Visitenkarte gegeben. Und zwar war das folgendermaßen, wurde ich von äh so wirklich Jugendlichen angesprochen. Also,
vielleicht waren die achtzehn, ja? Und äh meinten so, ja hier ähm sie, sie, sie, sie werden auf der Suche nach Koks,
Und da habe ich gesagt, ja Leute, da seid ihr bei mir falsch, ne. Und dann haben die gefragt, ja ähm ja wo denn, wo denn, wo denn, ne, wo man denn Koks bekommen würde, ne. Und dann habe ich denen gesagt, äh ey, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich hier, habe so in,
Richtung einer in Berlin für den Drogenhandel äh bekannten äh äh Parksituation gezeigt.
Gesagt, ne? Geht mal in den, da in den Park, werdet ihr wahrscheinlich euch nicht retten können vor Angeboten, aber hier, jetzt grade nicht, ne? Und dann und dann meinten sie, ja und ist das Gutes Koks? Ich so, ich habe keine Ahnung, aber vermutlich nicht so, ne.
Wenn die wenn die im Park stehen und das irgendwie ähm.
Pfeil bieten, ne? Und äh da meinten sie, ja wo kriegt man denn ein besseres Koks, ne? Und da habe ich gesagt, ey,
auch keine Ahnung, aber man hört viel von Koks Taxis so, ne? Und in dem Moment meinte dieser kleine Bubi da, eine achtzehn Jahre so, äh du bist korrekt und drück mir jetzt deine Visitenkarte in die Hand, die er wahrscheinlich gerade für seinen Kollegen oder sein,
Bruder verteilt und meint so, wenn du guckst, brauchst rufst du mich an.
Was ich eigentlich ganz äh ähm.
Hat es.
Sicherzustellen ähm nur potenzieller Kundschaft äh diese hm.
Visitenkarte in die Hand zu drucken, hat haben die mich auf jeden Fall überrascht.
Geil.
Aber äh ja äh besonders beeindruckt war ich eben nicht, weil es war halt eine ganz normale Handynummer wieder angegeben und ähm.
Na ja genauso viel zu Kokstaxi. Also ähm hier Glashäufer Umlauf, das ist aber wirklich ein Traum, diese dieses Video. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hast, äh.
Und es ist wirklich äh äh das Obsttaxi ist wirklich ähm gelungen. Late Night Berlin, machen wir auch in den in die Shownotes rein.
Kann ich äh wärmstens empfehlen.
Na, Obsttaxi ist ja eigentlich jetzt genau äh das Richtige für die aktuelle Situation, ne? Ja.
In dieser Jahreszeit, ne, eins A Banane und die sitzt dann.
Genau das Richtige für den Lockdown.
So
Lockdown Light ist, den man jetzt äh kriegen. Ja.
Lockdown light, hätte es ja auch ein geiler Begriff, ne. Als nächstes kommt der dritte Lockdown, ist der äh Lockdown Zero und dann kommt der äh Lockdown Pink Grapefruit oder Lockdown Crystal. Ähm.
Halten wir uns dazu äh halten wir uns dazu? Wollen wir noch über den Lockdown reden eigentlich?
Können wir machen? Frage ist, was man dazu äh sagen soll. Mir kommt's ja alles zu.
Merkel hat keine Ahnung. Merkel hat keine Ahnung, Alter. Merkel hat gesagt, ne? Zu Weihnachten haben wir neunzehntausend.
Panikmache. Ist noch gar nicht Weihnachten.
Ja, ich kenne auch so einige äh Wissenschaftler, die ganz toll angegeben haben. Das ist ja alles nur auf groben Schätzungen beruht und völlig übertrieben ist und soll man nicht hier irgendwie gleich so durchdrehen
Jetzt haben wir den Salat, ne? Also ich äh persönlich, ich kann's gar nicht erwarten.
Äh fand auf jeden Fall, wenn man die, also um mal den politischen Aspekt zu äh besprechen, was ich ähm eine interessante Debatte finde, ist tatsächlich die, dass ja also die Frage nach,
Dieser Lockdown-Sachen, die jetzt eine Frage des Parlamentes oder für das Parlament.
Oder für die Regierung. Dieser Lockdown Light wurde ja ähm wie der,
entschieden in einer Gruppe aus den Ministerpräsidentinnen und der Kanzlerin in irgendeinem äh äh Call und danach erst im Parlament diskutiert, worüber sich,
denke ich zu Recht einige der Parlamentarierinnen echauffiert haben gleichzeitig,
wenn man dann halt sieht, dass in an solchen Diskussionen halt solche Vollstrategen,
wie der Gauland teilnehmen, dann verstehe ich auch, dass die sagen, wir führen die Gespräche lieber im informierten Kreise. Äh wo übrigens mein neues Lieblingsgift äh bei rausgekommen ist.
Und zwar.
Reaktion von Karl Lauterbach auf die Rede von Gauland.
Ja.
Also es ist wirklich wieder man kann über den Laut einfach sagen, was man will, ne. Ähm der geht den Leuten natürlich auf den Sack und dass der die ganze Zeit recht hat,
Leuten natürlich noch mehr auf den Sack, ne? Aber der hat nun mal Recht. Ja, mit dem, was er sagt. Und ähm.
Das ist äh ähm ja sehr,
unterhaltsam zu sehen, wie der halt dann irgendwie auf jemanden reagiert, der wie der Gauland halt den ganzen Tag nur Quatsch redet, nur vor sich hin bräst, ich verstehe gar nicht, warum denen überhaupt irgendjemand zuhören kann, dem,
insofern volle Sympathie mit dem Armen Lauterbach, der sich den Gauland anhören musste.
Ähm wichtig finde ich ähm sollte man sicherlich auch an dieser Stelle erwähnen und das, denke ich, wäre etwas, wo man jetzt auch die Bundesregierung echt drauf festnageln muss, ist dieses
in diese in Aussichtstellung, dass diese Betroffenen Gewerbe und Branchen, die ja wieder
eine relativ willkürliche und nicht widerspruchsfreie Auswahl sind
Erstattungen bekommen sollen und zwar fünfundsiebzig Prozent des Umsatzes des Vormonats. Ähm was ja mal, ne, das gab's beim ersten Mal nicht,
Muss man äh muss man mal dazu sagen. Und ich denke, da muss man jetzt auch,
darauf achten, dass das auch wirklich so kommt und dabei bleibt. Und dann wäre jetzt vor dem Hintergrund ist so die Reaktion meiner Freundinnen und Freunde in der Gastronomie.
Dass sie sagen, im Prinzip, wenn das so ist und sie die fünfundsiebzig Prozent bekommen, sind sie eigentlich ganz froh.
Erstens, weil sie selber sagen so, ja, also das geschehen hier in dem in der Kneipe oder in dem Restaurant, war mitunter.
Ähm.
Besorgniserregend oder kompliziert, ja? Wird auch müssen ja gar nicht alles irgendwie sogenannte Corona-Paranoiker sein, sondern geht natürlich auch darum, dass ähm.
Personal sich auch keine Freunde macht, wenn sie die ganze Zeit ähm die Gäste auf irgendetwas hinweisen müssen, ne.
Ähm und zweitens war es ja zumindest hier in Berlin jetzt auch schon wieder seit zwei Wochen, glaube ich, so, dass die nur bis dreiundzwanzig Uhr aufmachen durft.
Natürlich auch eine äh eine starke ähm Belastung ist für den Laden.
Insofern denke ich, da gehört jetzt die Aufmerksamkeit hin, dafür zu sorgen, dass unsere Kulturstätten und unsere gastronomischen Einrichtungen durch diese,
durch dieses Versprechen eben dann auch geschützt werden. Und dann stellt sich mir natürlich weiterhin die Forderung, die ich immer wiederhole,
so, dass es im Moment eben eine Krise von denen, die Gewerbe haben oder die Jobs haben,
aber keine Krise, von denen die Kohle haben und insbesondere keine Krise, von denen die Immobilien haben. Und das wird jetzt langsam einmal Zeit, sich darüber Gedanken zu machen, wieso denn,
in dem Fall jetzt hier Restaurants und Kneipen.
Weiterhin eine volle Miete zahlen sollen, wenn sie.
Dass, wenn sie dieses Lokal nicht betreiben können, ja, diese Mieten orientieren sich ja an dem Erfolg oder diese Pacht, orientiert sich ja an dem Erfolg,
der der Lokale und der Umsätze, die die Vermieterin dann da vermuten, von denen sie möglichst viel abgreifen wollen und ähm ich denke, dass,
der richtige Ansatz bleibt dabei, ähm den einfach diese Entlastung zu nehmen und zu sagen, alles klar,
ihr könnt 'n Monat nicht öffnen, ihr müsst auch 'n Monat keine Miete zahlen und wir zahlen das auch nicht, weil nämlich Krise ist, Arschleckenliebe, Kapitalanleger, erwischt allemal, so ist das, bitter, wenn es 'ne Pandemie gibt, ja? Und dann,
kannst du ganz einfach sagen und für das Personal machen wir hier dieses Kurzarbeitsgeld und fertig. So, wenn dann wäre das alles gar kein so großartiges Problem.
Ja gut, ist ja nicht so, dass das äh dass jetzt ein Vermieter keine äh regelmäßigen Kosten hätte mit so einer Immobilie, da hast du natürlich auch äh schon noch Ausgaben. Ähm aber.
Doch hat doch jeder an.
Aber an den könnte man sich dann halt auch orientieren, ne.
Oder also ich finde auch ähm also man könnte zum Beispiel du, also wenn jetzt hier in eine eine in guter Lage Gastronomie in Berlin, weißt du, was die an Parchzahlen?
Das ist ja nicht so, als würden die ja irgendwie hä zehn oder fünfzehn Euro den Quadratmeter zahlen oder so was.
Da wird ja richtig, richtig äh reingebuttert.
Die Zahlen unglaubliche Mieten. Du kannst im Prinzip finanzierst du äh im äh verdient der Vermieter des Ladens mehr an dem Laden als die Betreiberin?
Das ist äh na ja, okay, lassen wir das.
Logbuch Gastronomiepolitik, also das können wir jetzt nicht äh ja, ich ich sehe da einen Punkt, klar, äh hätte könnte, äh man ist aber nicht getan worden. Es gibt jetzt zumindest den, den Ausfall äh,
ich meine, vor Monat dürfte wahrscheinlich auch nicht so gut gelaufen sein, ne? Also da wäre.
Ich mal, was ist denn, hätte, hätte, ist aber nicht getan worden, was soll es denn für ein Kommentar? Wir machen hier seit neun Jahren Logbuch Netzpolitik, haben wir jetzt irgendwie bei jedem Scheiß, der die Politik macht, einfach nur hätte, hätte, Fahrradkette, haben sie nicht gemacht, Staatstrojaner,
ja, na ja. Da muss man schon sagen können, dass das falsch ist, finde ich.
Haben wir ja jetzt auch getan, so, aber.
Ja, aber noch nicht oft genug.
Gutes. Willst noch mal einmal kurz? Ja.
Also ähm gut, ähm nächstes Thema. Oder willst du noch was zum Lockdown sagen? Du hast ja gesagt, du freust dich.
Ja, ich freu na, ich freue mich, dass ja, naja, ich freue mich insofern als dass es halt überfällig war, Maßnahmen zu beschließen, umso länger damit gewartet wurde, umso länger äh werden wir damit zu kämpfen haben, ja, also es wäre wahrscheinlich,
blicken wir eben auf vier Wochen das hätte wahrscheinlich Ende September noch ganz anders ausgesehen.
Aber ich sehe natürlich auch, dass du in der Politik das Problem hast.
Das soeben auch jetzt nicht irgendwelche Maßnahmen einfach mal so eben beschließen kannst. Ja, schon,
gar nicht, wenn du dann eben vielleicht auch noch so diese äh Notsituationslegitimation mit reinbringst, ne, was du meintest mit ja, sollst hier nicht lieber der Bundestag beschließen und ne, wer wer beschließt jetzt eigentlich solche Maßnahmen aufgrund,
ähm,
und natürlich war das dann im September noch nicht unbedingt so, dass alle das Gefühl hätten, man müsste das jetzt unbedingt tun, hätte man's trotzdem beschlossen,
Ja und das ist dann eben eine politische Abwägung. Wäre wahrscheinlich dann eben dieser Widerstand stärker gewesen, wie er ja, dass er jetzt auch ist, wird jetzt immer noch genug Leute geben, die sagen.
Lockdown und dann, was weiß ich, Verschwörungstheorie hier oder äh ungerecht da und überzogen da, aber in dem Moment läuft ja halt einfach die Zeit davon, ne? Und jetzt äh ist es ja ohnehin ein Experiment,
Schulen, Kindergärten sind halt nach wie vor offen. So, das ist schon nochmal so ein,
so ein Loch äh in diesem System, von dem ich noch nicht genau sagen kann oder von dem keiner, glaube ich, so genau sagen kann,
wie viel das der Effizienz dieses Lockdowns auch wieder nimmt, was es ja dann auch wieder potentiell alles verlängert. Und ähm ja, ich bin,
gespannt wie das ausgeht. Aber ich bin bin froh, dass das Maßnahmen ergriffen werden, weil sonst wär's äh.
Müssen wir nicht weit gucken in Europa, um zu sehen, was äh sonst passieren würde.
Ja also es ist steht zu hoffen, dass das die richtigen Maßnahmen sind, ne? Da muss man aber auch also ich,
da bin ich erstens unglücklich, dass es,
noch relativ wenig vertretbare
Erkenntnisse darüber gibt, ob diese Maßnahmen etwas bringen oder nicht, ne. Also die klassische Diskussion ist ja, äh ja, wenn man die Gesundheitsämter fragt, die meisten Infektionen gehen ja gar nicht auf die ins Gastronomie zurück, ganz im Gegenteil.
Und
dem ist natürlich entgegenzuhalten, naja die fünfundsiebzig Prozent der Infektionen kommen aus dem Nichts. Ähm das ist das Problem, ne, dass äh dass man eigentlich in den Griff
bekommen möchte und dann können das eben sehr wohl auch gastronomische äh Situationen sein. Ähm das ist ja so ein bisschen die,
ich sage mal, die die wissenschaftliche oder die Evidenz fokussierte äh Diskussion dazu. Ähm,
Ich glaube, dass viel dieser ähm Maßnahmen.
Eventuell vielleicht gar nicht eine Primärwirkung haben, sondern so eine Sekundärwirkung.
Vielleicht nicht, dass es also nicht unbedingt daran liegt, dass jetzt irgendwie äh was weiß ich, die Kneipen sind zu und auf einmal stecken sich die Leute nicht mehr an, weil sie sich weil oh, die haben sich die ganze Zeit alle in der Kneipe angesteckt, das kann ja auch nicht sein. Aber eventuell, dass eben die.
Menschen eben ihre Verhaltensweisen dann doch ähm anpassen, sinnvoll ändern und ähm.
Bewusst oder unbewusst Verhaltensweise nicht mehr zeigen, die tatsächlich das Infektionsgeschehen voranbringen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall in der ersten Welle so gewesen. Man hat das ja schon relativ klar gesehen, die Zahlen gingen schon zurück, noch bevor die drei großen Maßnahmen im Wochenabstand
wirklich beschlossen waren. Das heißt so die Bilder aus Italien und dieses ähm,
diese Wirkung sozusagen diese Schrittweise bei,
der einen schneller, der anderen äh langsamer vonstatten ging, so dieses oh wir haben jetzt hier wirklich ein Problem. Das alleine hat schon zu einer Verhaltensänderung geführt,
Natürlich haben wir jetzt gegenüber der Ersten Welle auch technische Vorteile. Es gibt Masten, mittlerweile auch weitgehend akzeptiert jetzt mal von den äh Idioten abgesehen,
ähm das heißt, wir schützen uns generell schon mehr und das wahrscheinlich auch in den Schulen mehr. Ja, nicht unbedingt jetzt optimal oder maximal und das ist alles, was man tun kann, aber so insgesamt. Und ich glaube, das ist das, worauf man,
vertraut und äh die Annahme, dass wir das,
dass wir in zwei Wochen das schon beenden können. Na, teile ich nicht. Also ich denke, das wird jetzt schon den ganzen November laufen müssen, damit die Zahlen halt auch wirklich runtergehen. Und dann werden auch die Maßnahmen sehr langsam gelockert werden, sodass man wahrscheinlich noch,
ins Weihnachten sozusagen das Ziel hat, so Weihnachten mit sehr niedrigen Zahlen zu starten.
Dann wieder alle nach Hause wollen und schön nochmal ein bisschen betreiben und dann möchte man eben mit relativ niedrigen Infektionszahlen in diese Weihnachtszeit.
Also das, das Jahr ist eigentlich durch. Also wenn wenn äh wenn die Uhr, wenn die Wahlen jetzt in den USA uns nicht noch ein Highlight äh geben, dann dann wird's,
finster, leider, sorry, tut mir leid, aber ist so.
Moment eh schon da, Alter. Wenn die, wenn die Wahl so ausgeht, ich glaube, da rufe ich sogar noch bei dem Koks-Taxi an.
Ich hätte gerne eine Banane und ein Kilo Weintrauben.
Habt ihr auch Klopapier?
Das habe ich übrigens auch gehört. Ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, aber das äh im ersten Lockdown wurde kolportiert. Das äh ich meine,
Taxis, ne, die agieren ja auch primär halt nach Angebot und Nachfrage und äh was schwer zu bekommen ist, äh dass die wohl auch äh bestimmte Sortimentserweiterungen hatten,
Weiß ich aber nicht, ob das äh einfach nur ein Scherz war,
Nee, aber das wird äh das wird die das wird äh die Party, wenn das äh also wenn Trump abgewählt wird.
Dann wird es die Party und zwar hier. Dann machen wir hier ein Fass auf, oder? Nächste Woche.
Im Internet. Ich hole mir eine Flasche Champagner.
Ja. Also entweder Schampus, Schampus äh oder Frust.
Du hast äh, du kannst es entscheiden. Wähle dein Herzblatt.
Äh je.
Nein, erst Entschuldigung, bevor das jetzt hier falsch verstellt wird, natürlich rufe ich nicht bei diesem Taxi an. Natürlich habe ich auch diese Visitenkarte weggeworfen. Bin doch nicht verrückt und äh äh schleppe solches äh Kompromat mit mir rum. So.
So einfach bist du nicht zu kriegen.
Nein. Wir kaufen nix an der Tür. So.
Schauen wir mal, äh was die USA noch so ähm im Köcher haben, solange sie uns noch und alle anderen äh uneingeschränkt piesacken können.
Ein äh Lieblingsobjekt äh ist ja auch unser Freund Edward Snowden,
der nun schon seit einigen Jahren in Russland festhängt, nachdem er so viel Wissenswertes über der Welt ausgekippt hat über die NSA, die CIA und überhaupt die gesamten US-amerikanischen
Behörden und insbesondere ihre geheimen Bereiche.
Und nachdem wir nun viele, viele Jahre der Berichterstattung hinter uns haben. Ähm.
Hat er ja auch ein Buch geschrieben mit dem Namen Permanent Record und dort ist dann halt äh viel dieses Wissens äh auch.
Wiederzufinden.
Die USA und sagt so, hm, aber das ist doch unsere Information und du durftest sie doch gar nicht weiter erzählen. Sondern da stand drin, wenn du das irgendwie äh jemandem weitererzählen willst,
da muss man uns vorher fragen, ist das ja nicht gemacht, also ist das unsere Kohle, die du mit diesem Buch verdient hast. So sieht es jetzt auch ein Bundesgericht in den USA. Virginia äh da haben sie dann ein Urteil, ein endgültiges Urteil gefällt,
eine entsprechende ähm Verfügung äh bestimmt, dass fünf Komma zwei Millionen Dollar,
ähm an kolportierten Einnahmen,
Buches, äh das ist aber nicht nur das Buch, sondern auch äh sechsundfünfzig Vorträge, die er äh noch zusätzlich gehalten hat, wo Einnahmen von, glaube ich, so achtzehntausend Dollar pro Vortrag äh angenommen wurden,
ordentliches Gehalt, so ein Vortrag will ich auch mal halten. Ähm ja und äh das stünde einfach den USA zu und äh,
her mit der Kohle. Mir ist ehrlich gesagt aus der Berichterstattung nicht so hundertprozentig klar geworden, inwiefern äh die USA jetzt schon in der Lage sind, hier Gelder explizit vom Verlag,
quasi abzuzweigen und ihm gar nicht erst zukommen zu lassen,
oder inwiefern das alles äh davon abhängt, dass äh ihm gegenüber persönlich das gültig gemacht werden muss.
Weil's Noten meint so, na ja äh könnt ihr ja gerne machen. Ich widerspreche dem jetzt erstmal, aber ähm.
Eigentlich kriegt ihr die Kohle nur, wenn ich wieder in den USA bin, nur dann könnt ihr sie bei mir eintreiben,
Also äh wäre doch sein Vorschlag für einen entsprechenden Nachrichtenartikel. USA äh könnten fünf Millionen Dollar daran verdienen, wenn sie ihn äh begnadigen.
Also ich fände jetzt mal so, fünf Millionen, ich.
Fände ich schon krass, wenn der äh so viel Geld damit verdient hätte.
Also ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt ist, schreibt er auch an äh an einer Stelle, dass er ähm das nicht,
dass er diese Art, diese Summengeld nicht äh verdient hätte. Ich glaube schon, dass der jetzt nicht irgendwie am Hungertuch neigt und dass der vielleicht für viele, für einige Vorträge auch mal eine ganz gute Summe kassieren konnte und sie.
Er hat gesagt.
Buch ganz gut verhandelt hat.
Er hat gesagt, er hätte so viel Geld noch nicht gehabt. Also, ich denke schon, dass ich das ganz gut verkauft habe, wie viel Gewinn dabei bleibt, wenn er noch so ein Verlag mit drin ist et cetera, keine Ahnung.
Bei dem Buch wird er natürlich einen sehr schönen Vorschuss und eine sehr gute Gewinnbeteiligung ausgehandelt haben, ja? Und ich
ich würde das jetzt auch nicht ausschließen, dass der vielleicht sechs oder siebenstellige Einnahmen dadurch hatte, aber fünf Millionen ähm er würde mir dann doch ähm.
Krass erscheinen.
Na ja, also er sagt ja auch selber, dass es, dass es, dass es, dass es nicht so viel ist. Naja, wie dem auch sei. Ich find's auf jeden Fall sehr stark, weil die
tatsächlich ist es, also warum die damit durchkommen, ist ja, weil er Verträge mit diesen Behörden hat und mit seinen Arbeitgebern. Also die Non-Disc-Clausur-Agreements, die ihnen dazu verpflichten.
Wenn er über diese Tätigkeit zu schreiben äh gedenkt, dass vorzulegen.
Das hätte er eben dem äh Justizministerium vorlegen müssen und ähm hat natürlich gesagt, naja, wenn ich das Buch dem Justizministerium vorgelegt hätte,
dann hätten die natürlich ähm die Hälfte davon rausgestrichen, das Ding zensiert,
Ja und äh außerdem durch diesen Zensurprozess, dann hätte er im Prinzip wahrscheinlich gegen die Zensur klagen müssen. Er hätte das Buch niemals schreiben können und sagt, sagt dann eben, ja, vor dem Hintergrund habe ich mich natürlich entschieden,
äh Zensur zu entgehen und damit natürlich aber auch die,
ähm Royalties quasi zu riskieren. Also das ist ein, dass das,
In diesem Risiko stand, war ihm wohl auch bewusst und das ist ja jetzt auch bewusst eingegangen, weil er auch gar keine andere Möglichkeit hatte, dieses Buch ähm zu veröffentlichen.
So sind sie die Helden.
Ja, ja, alles nicht so einfach. Gut.
Tja, dann haben wir in Finnland einen äh relativ äh geschmacklosen Fall von Patientendatenreichtum. Und zwar gibt es ein Unternehmen, das heißt,
und die haben fünfundzwanzig Therapiezentren in Finnland, Psychotherapiezentren.
Und ähm jetzt gibt es auf einmal eine Welle von Patientinnen, die per E-Mail,
ähm dazu aufgefordert werden ähm irgendwie ungefähr zweihundert Euro zu bezahlen, sonst würden die Transkripte,
ihrer ähm ihre oder die Notizen, Transkripte, ihrer Therapiesitzungen veröffentlicht.
Und ähm vermutlich sind da mehrere zehntausend Personen von betroffen.
Und ähm dann wurde dieser Sache natürlich nachgegangen. Die Menschen haben bei äh natürlich irgendwie bei Panik-Hotlines und so weiter angerufen, ne, was ja auch verständlich ist. Und ähm dann haben sie äh rausgefunden, es sieht wohl danach aus, dass der,
tatsächliche Zugriff wohl zwei Jahre her ist auf diese Daten. Das Unternehmen sagt, ja ja nee, keine Sorge, alles ab. Alles ab November zwanzig achtzehn ist sicher.
Sehr beruhigende Botschaft von dem von dem Unternehmen und ähm.
Dann haben sie aber wohl rausgefunden, dass irgendwo im Dark Web zehn Gigabyte von diesem Unternehmen herumliegen. Und das wahrscheinlich derjenige oder diejenigen, die ihr da jetzt versuchen, mit der Veröffentlichung Leute zu erpressen.
Ja, diese Erpressung äh nicht nicht stattfindet, ist äh nicht stattfinden kann, weil die Daten eh schon veröffentlicht sind. Wo womit also jetzt die beruhigende Botschaft äh ist, ey, ihr könnt die zweihundert Euro sparen, die Daten sind eh schon geliebt im Internet.
Ja, alles okay.
Tja, das hast du davon, wenn du also so was kommt von sowas und man man fragt sich halt auch so, warum ne, warum lernen,
Leute, das immer erst dann, wenn es halt zu spät ist.
Dass eben früher oder später alle Daten in irgendeiner Form ja gehackt, zugegriffen werden und liegen, ja? Und grade der Datenschutz spielt ja auch,
in diesen Diskussionen immer eine ja etwas unselige Rolle, weil ihm irgendwie Schuld daran gegeben wird,
diese äh Dinge irgendwie zu erschweren, unmöglich zu machen, ne? Wir dürfen gar nichts mehr wegen Datenschutz und so, ne? Dabei passen wir doch gut auf die Daten auf und wir brauchen ja die Daten. Ja,
Herzlichen Glückwunsch, ne? Da sind jetzt Menschen ähm wahrscheinlich in schweren seelischen Krisen, weil die Angst haben, dass irgendjemand die Dinge anschaut, die sie.
Therapeutischen Sitzungen unter der Schweigepflicht irgendwie ihren Therapeutinnen anvertraut haben.
Und hier ist dann eine Datenbank anvertraut haben. Ja, man ist dieses, warum lernt man's nicht? Die Frage ist wer muss hier eigentlich was lernen, ne? Also äh sicherlich bei so einem Unternehmen.
Vermut mal, dass es sich jetzt hierbei äh um ein Unternehmen handelt und nicht um eine.
Ja ja, die haben fünfundzwanzig Therapiezentren.
Genau. So äh gut, dann da ist es natürlich müsste sowas natürlich äh jetzt aus der Perspektive des Managements,
einfach schon mal als als finanzielles Risiko gesehen werden, ne, weil du natürlich, wie das jetzt hier auch natürlich der Fall ist, auf der einen Seite potentielle Strafzahlungen, Datenschutzgrundverordnung, ne, weil Daten veröffentlicht zu,
ermöglicht, was weiß ich, okay, ist jetzt zwanzig achtzehn. Na, wobei zwanzig achtzehn fällt es,
mit rein, ne? Genau, vor zwei Jahren war das auch schon in Kraft, ne?
Ich äh ich habe keine Ahnung, wie eventuell auch andere gesetzliche Regelungen in dem Bereich in Finnland aussehen. Kann ich leider.
Genau, dann Image verlost und so weiter, ne? Vertrauensverlust, äh dann gehen halt äh entsprechende Verträge in Zukunft vielleicht nicht an dieses Unternehmen. Also was ich damit sagen will, ist, dass das,
nicht nur irgend so eine Kleinigkeit ist, sondern das ist etwas, was man genauso wie Feuer äh Gefahr im Büro,
bewerten muss.
Mindestens so. Hier kann alles abbrennen, was passiert dann, ne? Gut, Versicherung ist das eine, Vorkehren ist das äh andere. Man muss dann halt immer so ein entsprechendes Assessment machen. Wie hoch ist denn das Risiko?
Andere Frage ist, wer könnte jetzt hier noch was falsch verstanden haben
Na ja, auch Leute, die so eine Datenbank designen oder die sagen auch für diese Datenerfassungen, diese ganzen Prozess und diese Entscheidung, welche Daten werden überhaupt genommen und wohin gespeichert auf welche Art und Weise. Auch da muss natürlich äh entsprechendes,
Wissen auch vorhanden sein und angewendet werden. Dann ist natürlich immer die Frage,
was ist jetzt der Maßstab, wer wer sagt dir, was quasi en vogue ist, was was ist so das Minimum
Gibt's da eine rechtliche Vorgabe vielleicht, so gibt's irgendwie Best Practice? Also es äh fordert ja auch ein gewisses.
Ähm eine gewisse Kompetenz, eine Gesamtkompetenz jetzt, das des Unternehmens, ne? Natürlich auch immer in den in den einzelnen Fällen und,
Na ja, man sieht einfach immer wieder, es dauert noch. Es dauert einfach noch bis Unternehmen und Organisationen,
so ganz selbstverständlich drauf haben, dass das ein wichtiges Thema ist.
Tja. Und die Leidtragenden sind äh die Menschen. Ist ja nicht so, als wäre wären die Unternehmen jetzt die Leidtragenden, ne?
Also äh ich denke, wir wir reden ja hier, ne, von Patientinnen und Patienten, denen äh deren Situation finde ich eigentlich sehr viel bedauerlicher.
Die das äh des Unternehmens. Nun. Ähm.
Wir haben in den letzten Wochen immer wieder darüber gesprochen, dass es Bestrebungen gibt.
In die verschlüsselte Kommunikation einzugreifen. Wir haben geschildert, dass das die Five Eyes äh ausgegeben haben als die Wiese. Wir haben auch schon,
ähm darüber gesprochen, dass äh die ähm der EU im Moment die,
wie heißen die jetzt schon wieder? Die deutsche Ratspräsidentschaft, genau, ne, also damit im Prinzip die,
Bundesrepublikierung, die jetzt die Präsidentin des Europarates ist, sagen, alles klar, wir hätten gerne ähm
Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung. Ähm mit anderen Worten, wir hätten gerne Zugriff auf äh verschlüsselte Daten, denn Strafverfolgungs-und Justizbehörden müssen in der Lage sein, recht
mäßig und gezielt auf Daten zuzugreifen. Ähm und deswegen müssen natürlich dabei müssen natürlich die Grundrechte geschützt werden und der Datenschutz, aber
und die Cyber-Sicherheit auch, die Cyber-Sicherheit auch, aber man braucht technische Lösungen für den Zugang zu Verschlüsse in Daten,
du fragst dich ernsthaft, wie die das, wie die so wie das jemand so schreiben kann, ne, dass du sagst, ja, wir müssen äh also wir brauchen absolute Verschlüsselung, aber wir brauchen natürlich Zugriff auf die Inhalte, ist ja wohl klar,
wir brauchen kompromisslose Cybersicherheit, brauchen wir Tim. Kompromisslose Cybersicherheit, aber natürlich nur für uns, nicht für die Kriminellen. Also.
Tja und äh sagen, haben ja jetzt, ne, nur um das nochmal zusammenzufassen. In Deutschland haben wir ja gerade erst mal die letzten Sendungen behandelt, äh die Situation das Anbieter wie WhatsApp, Signal, Skype, Threema, wer auch immer, Zoom, ja, ähm.
Und ja, quasi gezwungen werden können sollen. Äh technische Mittel einzubringen zur für eine Quellen-TKÜ.
Und ähm,
geht die Reise jetzt hin. Wir haben's in der letzten Sendung schon ausführlicher besprochen, warum das eben auch so eine fürchterliche Idee ist, wenn die Leute dann nämlich ihren eigenen Geräten nicht mehr vertrauen. Das ist nun mal ein Unterschied, leider,
zwischen einem Telefon, ne, wo alle wissen, jo, das Telefon kann abgehört werden, ne. Ähm und einem einer Applikation, äh die,
mitunter sehr viele andere Funktionalitäten auch in sich verbirgt und auf einem Gerät ist dem eben sehr viel mehr vertrauliches,
ähm zugeführt wird. Tja, inzwischen.
Wollen sie das also jetzt auf EU-Ebene vorantreiben? Die Five-Eisen machen's auch. Damit macht das im Prinzip die komplette, ja, westliche Welt und ähm,
der äh Datenschutzbeauftragte Ulrich Käber kritisiert währenddessen dann nochmal hier die ähm.
Novelle des BND-Gesetzes fließ eben auch,
zu erwarten war. Also alle wissen alle, die halbwegs sich darüber Gedanken machen, stehen daneben und sagen, das ist gefährlich, was ihr hier tut, aber das hindert natürlich diese ganzen Regierungen dieses Planeten nicht daran, damit trotzdem,
weiter voranzuschreiten. Auch an Tagen, wo sie grade mal wieder irgendwelche Telegramm, Drogenhändler ähm mit großen Aktionen,
äh gekriegt haben, obwohl sie in irgendwelchen Gruppen Pseudonym kommunizieren.
Ursel er hat jetzt wochenlang versucht die Nummer von dem Guckstaxi rauszukriegen, aber äh war nicht erfolgreich, aber wir müssen dann entsprechende gesetzliche Maßnahmen eingeleitet werden.
So ein Quatsch, ey. So dann ähm.
Ähm es war denn ähm,
warum warum äh berichte ich da nochmal kurz drüber? Ja, weil sich jetzt ein ähm Journalist äh äh von der ARD äh Florian Flader heißt ja glaube ich mal, angeschaut hat, was ist eigentlich aus dieser,
geworden. Die wurde vor drei Jahren gegründet,
ähm und irgendwie hat man nur noch wenig davon gehört. Zieht es, das ist dieses Akronym, wo ich immer noch mal ganz schnell googeln muss und währenddessen einfach Füllsätze sage, um herauszufinden, wofür ähm,
steht. Die zentrale Stelle für oh, jetzt kommt da ein Cookie-Banner drüber.
Zentrale Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich.
Genau, zentral.
Einem doch locker von der Zunge.
Genau, die suchen die äh Ava, ne, man denkt, hä, ist das nicht das BSI? Nein, nein. Die machen ja Unterstützung und,
pertise für Sicherheitsbehörden. Und nachdem die gegründet wurden, war's erstmal immer so, ja, ja, wir wurden jetzt hier gegründet und dann ist erstmal nix mehr weiter passiert, ne? Haben sie gesagt, wir brauchen jetzt Mitarbeiter. Es gibt uns jetzt und jetzt, wo wo es uns gibt, können wir überhaupt erst, ne, Arbeitsverträge
anbieten. So und inzwischen haben die aber mehr als einhundertachtzig,
Mitarbeiter und planen zum Ende des Jahres sogar zweihundertzwanzig zu haben. Und ähm was die machen ist, naja einmal im Jahr treff trifft sich quasi die Zitis mit den Sicherheitsbehörden und die Sicherheitsbehörden,
geben ihren Bedarf an und sagen dann, ja, wir wollen einmal äh hier WhatsApp und so, ne, und Telegram und haste alles nicht gesehen.
Äh welche technischen Probleme diese bei den Ermittlungen haben und wo
Technologie eventuell die Arbeit der Ermittler erleichtern könnte und daraus haben sie äh äh machen sie sich dann eben eine Jahresarbeitsprogramm und aktuell arbeiten sie an vierzig Projekten,
sind aber alle Geheimwerten auch den ähm Abgeordneten nicht mitgeteilt in den Kontrollgesprächen.
Ähm da sind dann so Sachen bei, wie die Spezifikation eines einheitlichen Datenformates beim Auslesen beim forensischen Auslesen von Mobiltelefonen, das ist eben, ne? Also das haben sie dann mal äh,
gesagt, dass sie daran arbeiten, weil das relativ unverfänglich ist, aber natürlich äh
sagen sie, äh wir geben aber zu den Fähigkeiten und Methoden, der CITIS, die Rückschlüsse auf die technischen und operativen Ermittlungsfähigkeiten der der Sicherheitsbehörden erlauben, grundsätzlich keine Auskunft
äh weil ne, die Ermittlungsfähigkeiten der Sicherheitsbehörden könnten ja dadurch gefährdet werden.
Ja jeder kommen.
So und äh jetzt natürlich auch, das finde ich ja auch ein sehr äh entscheidenden Satz. Äh die Zieht es, soll Sachen selber lösen, ne,
und die kaufen jetzt, also Citys sind nicht zum Beispiel die Kunden von Finn Fischer, aber äh ihre Aufgabe, zu ihrer Aufgabe gehört sehr wohl die Marktsichtung, sodass ähm,
die also nicht selber einkaufen, aber zum Beispiel Geheimdienste und äh Sicherheitsbehörden beraten, wo sie einkaufen können,
Ja, auch das ähm tja, ich fand das mal, ich fand's sehr interessant, da mal ein bisschen zu ähm,
etwas zu zu hören, was da jetzt so draus geworden ist, ne, weil äh da muss natürlich ein Auge draufgehalten werden, was da der die deutsche.
Exekutive sich jetzt hier für äh,
Forschung betreibt, äh im IT-Sicherheitsbereich, der natürlich immer, wenn die das machen, letztendlich das Gegenteil von IT-Sicherheit bedeutet, ne? Deswegen sagen sie auch Sicherheitsbereich und nicht IT-Sicherheitsbereich.
Sehr löblich im Übrigen, dass äh sich der Journalist hier Florian Flader vom WDR das offensichtlich ähm gleich auf Wiedervorlage gelegt hat.
Ja, so nach dem Motto Behörde, ach da gucken wir doch in zwei Jahren nochmal, was was damit ist,
würde ich jetzt mal so unterstellen, dass das so gelaufen ist. Ähm und äh ich habe gerade nochmal so auf diesen Artikel, äh den wir da verlinken, Tagesschau geschickt und dann war da rechts so aus dem Archiv.
Wiederum ein anderer Artikel, ein Jahr rätseln über Überwachungstechnik, Behörde Zithes zwanzig achtzehn und nach Hackerattacke braucht Bundestag ein neues IT-Netz, zwanzig fünfzehn,
und äh das finde ich jetzt gerade mal erwähnenswert, weil,
so jahrelang immer über dieses automatische Löschen von von solchen äh Artikeln der öffentlich rechtlichen gesprochen haben, ne? Und,
Man muss einen sehr ähm äh ein Elefantengedächtnis eigentlich ins Web tragen,
immer wieder zurückschauen und sagen so hier was weiß ich,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt's wieder Neuigkeiten. Ist übrigens ein Wiedergänger von letztes Jahr, das Jahr davor
davor, nochmal davor und hier ist die ganze lange Liste und jetzt kannst du wahrscheinlich auch nochmal vor zwanzig Jahren auch nochmal schauen, was damals die Argumentation war und es war immer noch der selbe Käse,
ne? Und äh das das äh wollte ich einfach an der Stelle nochmal erwähnen, dass es sehr wichtig ist, äh dafür zu streiten, dass solche Inhalte nicht gelöscht werden.
Ordentlich verlinkt werden.
Apropos Inhalte löschen. Ähm eines meiner meistverwendetsten und praktischen Tools wurde von Gittap entfernt.
Also es wurde versucht.
Bitten, der Recording-Industrie, der RIA. Das sind wahrscheinlich die mit dem Hogan Taping Kiste Music Industrie, ne.
Und die haben,
gesendet. Das Gitter eben das äh Entwicklungsreport von äh YouTube DEL,
Bitte ähm entfernen möge. Was ist YouTube DE? Ähm ja, macht genau das, was äh dran steht. Ähm ist in der Lage,
YouTube-Videos herunterzuladen. Aber nicht nur das, das funktioniert auch bei Tweets, das funktioniert bei allen möglichen ähm Webplayern, die ja,
Am Ende alle auf eine sehr ähm simple,
Technik setzen, die ihr irgendwie ein Videofight zu geben. Und unterschiedliche Techniken anwenden, damit du da jetzt nicht einfach eine Datei hast, auf die du zugreifst und die du runterladen kannst, ne, sodass sie dann irgendwie.
Eigene Wege bauen, dir die Datei möglichst verhackstückelt, äh zugänglich zu machen oder im Quelltext der Seite nicht sauber stehen zu haben, wo die Datei ist und wie sie heißt.
Ja, aber am Ende ist es eine Videodatei, die ist mit einem bekannten Code kodiert und die kann offenbar,
heruntergeladen werden, sonst wäre dein Computer ja nicht in der Lage, sie abzuspielen. Und äh YouTube, DL ist eben eine,
denke äh ich glaube, dass es in Peifen geschrieben,
eine Sammlung an Skripten, die auf den unterschiedlichsten Seiten, insbesondere eben auch YouTube.
Dieses Zeug auseinanderklamüsert und herausfindet, alles klar, wo ist denn jetzt mal die Datei, die ich einfach mal runterladen muss. Und ähm.
Ja, die RIA sagt jetzt also der klare äh Zweck dieses Quellkodes ist es, ähm.
Kopierschutzmechanismen zu umgehen ähm und Musik und Video zu reproduzieren und zu verteilen.
Die unseren Mitgliedern gehören, äh ohne, dass man dass wir das, dass unsere Mitglieder das genehmigt hätten,
und das finde ich schon echt stark, weil,
Also auf YouTube gibt's eine ganze Menge. Ja und eine ganze Menge Sachen, wo's Sinn macht, die runterzuladen. Und das Letzte, was ich mir von YouTube runterladen würde, wären irgendwelche Musikvideos, weil die Soundqualität da einfach Scheiße ist.
Ja oder auch die Videoqualität. Ja, es ist.
Na ja. Diese Videoqualität auch, ja, also.
Ja, ich meine, sie haben sich natürlich hier äh mal wieder der ganzen Sache einen Bärendienst äh erwiesen. Ich frage mich immer, was,
was sie da eigentlich dazu bringt, ne? Ich meine, das ist so ein bisschen so äh ja, wir wollen jetzt mal hier Stärke zeigen. Ist ja auch nicht so, dass es mittlerweile keine Möglichkeiten gäbe, ähm,
Wenn man sich das ja bei Netflix und so weiter, die übertragen ihren Kram ja auch über Step, aber dann kommen halt entsprechende
Copyright Systeme dort zum Einsatz. Das heißt, der Content ist ja, gibt verschlüsselt übers Netz, wenn er irgendwie
jedem Webangeboten wird. Äh das ist natürlich bei YouTube jetzt nicht der Fall. Würden die das machen, würde es äh wahrscheinlich zu einer Katastrophe äh führen. Ähm,
Obwohl ich das für die Zukunft gar nicht mal ausschließen würde, ne. Also es äh durchaus vorstellbar, dass wir da auch nochmal hinkommen, dass der komplette Videokram, der bei YouTube angeboten wird, äh eben auch auf diese Art und Weise verschüsselt wird,
So ist es aber derzeit nicht.
Da haben wir übrigens schon vor ähm einiger Zeit darüber diskutiert, als es darum ging, dass Indie Browser nämlich dann ein Blop rein sollte, also ein nicht quelloffener Teil
der die ähm DRM-Verschlüsselung im Prinzip beinhaltet,
Ja, wo du also quasi wo ein,
Dadurch, dass er nicht quäl offen ist, soll er eben, soll eben dann verhindert werden, dass du das und herausfindest, wie diese ähm Verschlüsselung hier stattfindet. Tatsächlich ist es ja so, die Leute, die jetzt irgendwie Netflix oder ähm.
Oder äh Amazon Video rippen. Die lassen einfach den Film laufen und zeichnen ihren Bildschirm auf.
So was, die machen sich gar nicht die Mühe, irgendwelche Downloads oder sonstiges zu triggern, ähm was natürlich auch eine, also diese Methode wird immer funktionieren. Insofern,
Und das ist auch eine sehr viel einfachere als jetzt irgendwie das YouTube-DL. Ich meine, das ist ein Command-Line-Tool, da geht's doch schon los. Da hast du schon irgendwie neunundneunzig Prozent der Nutzer äh und Nutzerinnen ausgeschlossen.
Ja, also immer, ich wollte nur mal klarmachen, wofür dieses Werkzeug jetzt eigentlich wirklich praktisch ist. So und jetzt ist ja jetzt ähm wird ja aber bei vielen hier,
Zum täglich Brot gehören, die hier zuhören, bei vielen allerdings auch so immer so ein bisschen Respekt äh Haltung ähm auslösen
das ist in diesem Fall, also ich meine, wenn ihr schon immer mal eine nützliche Commandline mal ausprobieren wolltet, dann wäre Youtube DEL für euch wahrscheinlich genau das Richtige. Alles, was man machen muss, ist man installiert, ist einmal, das geht in der Regel äh mit einer Zeile
die man vorher eingibt, ja? Und dann.
Hat man das Tool installiert und dann ruft man auf der Kommandozeile nur noch auf, YouTube DE und dann die URL von irgendeinem YouTube-Video,
oder eben auch wie mir oder andere Plattformen, die alle mehr oder weniger dort auch unterstützt werden, aber mit YouTube haben sie natürlich mal angefangen. Und dann guckt er halt, in welchen Formaten liegt denn das vor und weiß dann eben, wie man damit sprechen kann. Und es gehört auch zu den Open Saurs Projekten, glaube ich,
am häufigsten aktualisiert werden. Da ist die Versionsnummer tatsächlich das Datum, dass man halt immer sehen kann, aha,
habe ich jetzt auch wirklich was Topaktuelles und nicht mehr aktuell ist YouTube-DL,
Naja, so nach einer Woche oder zwei manchmal schon, ne? Weil sich dann in irgendeiner Webseite wieder die Ausspielung verändert hat, weil das hatte im L dort anders,
wird das Video anders dargestellt wird, dann wird das halt äh schnell nachgeschaut. In den Code eingearbeitet, ein Update gemacht und na ja und das lag halt,
alles bei Gitter rum. Und jetzt haben,
hat die Ria halt gesagt, sogar hier äh Copyright in, macht mal weg und ähm Microsoft letztlich, muss man sagen, ne, als Owner von äh Gitarp hat dem dann halt entsprochen und hat irgendwie dieses
dann einfach weggenommen. Was natürlich.
Irgendwo auch eine verdammt dumme Nummer ist, weil was natürlich dann sofort passierte war, dass YouTube DE, was natürlich in,
Tausenden aber tausenden Kopien auf
unheimlich vielen Computern rumliegt, von den Leuten einfach in ihrer eigenen Gitter-Repos äh auf Gitter hochgeladen wurde. Das heißt, wo es vorher vielleicht ein YouTube-Dell gab oder vielleicht zehn Varianten davon, gibt's jetzt
aber tausende Kopien quer verteilt und ums Ganze noch so richtig schön lustig zu machen äh hat jemand auch noch eine,
Sicherheitslücke ausgenutzt, die seit,
Wochen und Monaten und wie schon beklagt wird, wo aber Getup gesagt hat, oah nee, fixen wir nicht und ich weiß nicht, äh hast du dir die mal angeschaut, diese Sicherheitslücke? Auf jeden Fall ist es darüber möglich,
äh dass du in das Repositor von jemand anderem Code reinlädst, was natürlich eigentlich überhaupt nicht geht, ne?
Total komisch, aber aber das heißt aber, also ähm,
geht selber ist ja durch eine Blockchain gesichert tatsächlich, ne, eine. Ähm und deswegen wird das, wenn du das auscheckst, kommt der Code nicht mit. Aber in der Weboberfläche,
wird der quasi dargestellt.
Ja, also ein Problem von Gitarb, nicht von ist ja quasi eine eine webbasierte äh Online-Community von Developern
die unter Verwendung der Technologie eben dieses Hosten von Code erlaubt und dann eben auch das schnelle Teilen und Gitarb konkret selber hat halt dieses Problem, sodass jemand,
diesen YouTube-Code ausgerechnet in von selber, wo nämlich diese ganzen
Copyright Violation äh Entscheidungen veröffentlicht werden dort den Code reingestellt, was natürlich auf jeden Fall nochmal ein Bienchen oben drauf kriegt.
Ja, also euer Einstieg in die Command-Line-Welt, YouTube DE, extrem praktisch. Ich benutze das
am laufenden Meter. Wenn wir hier irgendwelche Clips einspielen und äh äh lustige Sachen machen, das ist immer das Erste, was man macht. Man macht erstmal eine Kopie,
dann ist wieder weg und dann was weiß ich, hat man kein Netz
man will das halt auch in Ruhe äh beschneiden und ordentlich nachhören oder einfach auch für sich privat wegarchivieren, wo ich jetzt wirklich den den Kern nutzen eigentlich sehe und man kann einen eben schön über die Option des Tools auch noch einstellen, in welchem Format man's gerne runtergeladen haben will, ja, weiß ich. Wenn man nur das Audio von einem Video haben will, dann,
man das oder wenn man das Video in der aller größtmöglichen Qualität archivieren möchte, dann kann man das dort spezifizieren, das ist halt einfach super.
Top-Tool und ähm,
Ja, ich meine, also ich frage mich auch, was der Quatsch soll. Der ist es ist halt ärgerlich, also die die setzen natürlich auf Gitter ähm als ähm Entwicklungscommunity, wo halt sehr viele pulig festkommen aus der Community, ne. Ähm
die Verbreitung des Tools wird dadurch ähm weniger behindert als halt die gezielte, koordinierte schnelle ähm.
Ja Weiterentwicklung auch, ne, weil du sonst siehst, ah okay, hier gibt's einen Bug, guck mal kurz,
rein, alles klar, hier schmiert er ab, das muss geändert werden, zippe zappe und äh dann hast du YouTube DL wieder funktioniert, ne? Oder hast du eine neue Quelle mit hinzufügen können und genau dieser Entwicklungsprozess wird jetzt,
dadurch ähm gestört.
Naja gut, er wird zumindest von Gitter weggenommen. Ich meine, man kann natürlich diesen Code nach wie vor irgendwo auf irgendwelchen Servern.
Genau, aber der, die Maintainer müssen ja trotzdem gerne, ne, die wollen, also es ist ja schon so, Code ist deshalb auf Github, weil man dort eine sehr,
lebhafte, schöne äh Entwickler-Community hat, die,
eben genau relativ einfach mit und so weiter mitmachen kann. Und wenn ihr jetzt auf GIT Lab gehen dann haben sie den nächsten DMC Akedown oder was, ne? Das ist also irgendwie, na ja.
Tja, Bitburg.
Aber haben wir jetzt genug, auch dafür geworben, dass wir der zweite Werbeblock äh bei uns heute hier. Lasst uns noch ein Sternchen auf iTunes da und empfehlt uns.
Das könnte aber tatsächlich machen. Empfehlen dürft ihr uns. Also wir wir freuen uns immer über neue Hörerinnen und Hörer und über die stetig wachsenden äh Zuhörerzahlen.
Auch ohne.
Alles klar. Das bringt uns jetzt zu den Terminen, ne?
Werbeblock, genau, Termine.
Am zwölften November findet statt ein kleiner Online-Talk im Nord-Süd-Forum München. Spionage-Software in München. Weltweit eingesetzt,
illegal exportiert Fragezeichen, um äh neunzehn Uhr, da wird sein ähm Sarah Linken von der äh GF.
Die ähm die sind quasi diese Strafanzeige der GF ähm betreut dort und die auch,
mit der wir dann auch quasi hier zusammengearbeitet haben als Thorsten und ich unsere Analyse dabei gesteuert haben neben ja vielen anderen auch, hatte ich ja auch schon erwähnt,
und äh Beo Wolf Tomek äh ein freischaffender Künstler, der ähm sich damit anfangen,
zwanzig zwanzig auch auseinandergesetzt hat und die werden halt in einem Button ein bisschen darüber sprechen und wer also.
Im Detail sich zu über dieses, für dieses Ermittlungsverfahren interessiert, ähm hat da glaube ich mit Sarah die kompetenteste Ansprechpartnerin.
Ja und am siebenundzwanzigsten Dezember gibt's die Remote Chaos Experience, darauf wurde ja schon äh hingewiesen und sehr viel mehr als darauf hinweisen, äh kann man jetzt eigentlich auch nicht. Äh es wird wohl demnächst ein CFP geben. Da weißt du aber mehr als ich, oder?
Ja, wir müssen noch ein bisschen überlegen, wie das dann läuft mit den Essen, mit den Community-Bühnen hatte ich ja beim letzten Mal schon drüber gesprochen und deswegen äh zieht sich das noch ein bisschen hin. Es wird aber,
etwas. Es wird etwas geben, also macht euch bitte schon mal darüber Gedanken. Genauso wie der Käufer, den ich ja in den letzten Folge schon erwähnt hatte, ne, wo es also um.
Eure Chaos-Studios gibt, geht um eure vielleicht eigenen Community-Bühnen.
Und auch einfach eure kleine Repräsentanz im Internet. Da ist schon irgendwie bald annähernd hundert haben sich da schon angemeldet, also die Sache,
läuft und vielleicht ist das das andere worauf man sich am Ende des Jahres noch ein bisschen freuen kann.
Alright. Ja, das bringt uns dann wie immer ans Ende der Sendung.
Hast du noch Dank für uns, für alle.
Ja, ich habe äh besonderen Dank an Sven, der.
Als äh einziger unseren Jahrestag hier äh zur Kenntnis genommen hat, auf seinem Konto.
Ähm und äh dann gibt ein herzlicher und wiederholter Dank an Maren und Wolfgang.
Und ein lieber Dank an Claudia, ähm die vier haben mir in der letzten Woche Freuden bereitet. Das hat mich sehr gefreut.
Ja und viel äh Freude habt ihr uns auch bereitet, die ihr uns in den letzten neun Jahren so begleitet habt
das jetzt gar nicht weiter überhöhen, aber ich finde das dann doch irgendwie erstaunlichen Zeitraum, auch wenn es jetzt so eine krumme Zahl ist, ähm,
aber neun Jahre sind immerhin auch neun Jahre schon mehr als eine Katze.
Nee, wie mehr als eine Katze.
Um sieben Jahre.
Katze ist, glaube ich, einundzwanzig geworden oder so, die war nicht klein zu kriegen.
Ach so, ich verwechsle das, glaube ich, mit Hundejahren oder irgendwie so.
Verwechselst das du verwechselst das wahrscheinlich mit dem Hamster oder so. Ein Hamster wird nicht neu.
Ja, okay, ist mehr, mehr, mehr als Hamster.
Wir upgraden gerade von Hamster auf auf Hund.
Und dann vielleicht auf Katze, mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt.
So und äh ja, bitte, bitte fiebert mit. Ach so, wenn ihr ach so, an unsere äh Heurerinnen in den USA, bitte wählen gehen, ne.
Euer. Das wird jetzt den Ausschlag gegeben haben. Bin mir sicher.
Ich meine, die Mobilisierung ist schon da, ne? Also die Frage ist halt nur, wie wie sehr
Republikaner zu bescheißen. Das ist die eigentliche Frage. Das das äh Votum an sich. Klar gegen Trump ist, glaube ich, steht komplett außer Frage
man muss halt nur am System vorbei.
Immer das Problem. Dann wünschen wir euch noch äh viel Erfolg äh dabei am System vorbeizukommen, welches auch immer sich grade euch in den Weg stellt. Äh ihr werdet da schon erfolgreich sein können.
Tipps für den Lockdown haben wir ja fürsorglich und vorausschauend wie wir sind, schon in der vorvorletzten Folge gegeben,
Insofern oder vorletzten, ich weiß nicht, es gab auf jeden Fall, gab's Tipps, ich hab auch gesehen, dass ihr da den Empfehlungen teilweise gefolgt seid. Ähm, ansonsten, ne, achtet auf Bewegung,
achtet auf Licht und so weiter.
Und darauf, dass ihr auch die nächste Folge von Lokboot Netzbrief nicht verpasst.
Ja, wobei, wie gesagt, also wenn das Risiko Depression im Raum steht, kann die nächste Folge, je nachdem, ähm auch eine sein, die man lieber skippen möchte.
Ja, es gibt einen, wir haben wir haben einen schönen Bonustrack von Bruce Springsteen.
Wir sagen jetzt tschüss.
Tschau.